[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
we look ahead to an upcoming hearing for
scott peterson convicted nearly two
decades ago for murdering his pregnant
wife lacy
a judge suddenly drops one of the
charges against ex-cop derek chovin in
the alleged murder of george floyd
we explain why and what it means for the
case
plus a stunning 9-1-1 call of a teen
struggling to breathe as he's trapped
under a car seat in a freak accident
the lawsuit seeks to blame the city for
failing to find him
law and crime daily covers court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
and welcome everybody to law and crime
daily i'm aaron keller along with brian
buckmeyer and terry austin a minnesota
judge drops third degree murder charges
against
derek chauvin one of the four officers
accused of killing george floyd
but the other charges including a more
serious second-degree murder charge
remain
in place against chauvin all the other
charges against all the other officers
involved will stand the state has five
days to appeal the decision
the judge dug deep into the third degree
murder statute of his state and
here's the issue third degree murder
requires the act which causes
the death of another here that's george
floyd to be
eminently dangerous to others note the
plural
the judge says the others referenced in
the law
cannot be the same person who actually
died so
brian buckmeyer explain why this is so
important that one letter s yeah so that
letter is really what the defense is
hanging their hat on to get that second
murder charge
out the door now it really makes it easy
for them at trial because really the aim
here
is to get rid of that top murder charge
and if they can do that
they drop drastically down to
manslaughter that could be and at least
in the defense's eyes somewhat of a win
so terry advocates for george floyd
including ben crump applauded the
decision saying it left every other
charge in place
except this one lesser charge so the big
charges are all still there
but does that make it harder for
prosecutors to convict in this case
because as we know oftentimes
prosecutors
rely on those lesser charges so if a
jury doesn't see a top charge they can
go through a list
that's exactly right aaron the risk of
dropping the lesser charges that the
juror won't have any place to convict
for if you know the higher charge is a
backup for the jury
and here if they drop that lesser charge
then uh you know the jury is going to be
left looking as to what to do and
essentially the difference in the
penalties for second degree
is up to 40 years and up to 25 for a
third degree so
if you drop that lesser and the jury
can't find enough for the higher charge
you're basically left with as brian
mentioned just the manslaughter charge
and
you know the penalty for that is just
seven to ten years so
i i think it's not going to help the
prosecution very disparate senator
thank you brian was the uh was the
judge's statutory interpretation sound
here
maybe i think it's a very narrow way to
interpret the statute uh obviously it's
supported by cases that follow the same
logic
but if there are cases that the
prosecution can show dismantles that
logic that you can in fact
target an individual and act eminently
dangerous and so that one individual you
targeted died
then that statute and that crime is back
on the table good input from brian
buckmeyer and terry austin on that
report
the california case of convicted killer
scott peterson is returning to the trial
court level
a hearing will likely help determine
whether prosecutors will push
for the death penalty against peterson
or whether they'll let him remain in
prison for life
an appeals court struck down peterson's
death sentence over the summer
and in a separate ruling the appeals
court also ordered a judge to determine
whether peterson needed a whole new
trial
because a juror lied about previous
contacts with the criminal justice
system
a jury in 2004 famously convicted
peterson
of killing his pregnant wife lacey
peterson joining me live here on the
broadcast right now is former scott
peterson attorney laura
yaretzian so laura the topic of this
upcoming hearing is a bit of a question
mark officially could it simply be a
request for another delay or could it
dig into one of these big appeals issues
are we talking about the topic that's
going to come up tomorrow
if that's what it is my understanding is
tomorrow the court is basically just
trying to figure out if scott has an
attorney
the topic that the most recent decision
by the court
was that the courts basically sent the
case back to
the lower court at this point it's in
stanislaus county
to decide whether what this whether the
grants got
a a new trial based on what had happened
the prejudicial conduct bought
by one of the jurors do you think it's
even remotely possible that the state
will roll over and not go for the death
penalty again
if there is a second trial or even to
deal with the appeals issue here of the
punishment
i mean anything is possible uh the
public view or opinion has changed a
little bit
uh based on some of the some of the
shows that we've sent someone has seen
some of the documentaries that have come
out
some of the information that's come out
for one example
is what the court's done now some of the
information that's come out about
about jurors i mean we had stealth
jurors a lot of jurors a lot of people
tried to get on that
jury and one example is this particular
juror number seven
who obviously lied her way to get on
that jury i mean she lied about
something substantial
very important and this was someone who
clearly had an agenda
and made up her mind to get on that jury
any way possible and had made up her
mind about scott
she was going to convict them no matter
what and that's exactly what she did
and the defense's position is that that
was poisonous to the rest of the jury so
obviously a big deal in the defense's
eyes most of the state's case though was
ruled by the appeals court to remain
intact in other words it was mostly
sound so does that say anything about
the factual guilt
of your former client not necessarily
not necessarily once he's hopefully he's
given another shot
at a new trial and this is a case that
was based on circumstantial evidence
there was no forensic evidence
whatsoever connecting him to the
crimes involved and once
a an unbiased jury a jury that it's that
has not made up its mind
listens to this evidence and decides
i think things will be different he
deserves and anyone any defendant
deserves
a fair trial and i
if given a fair trial i think things
will come out differently it would be a
big
huge change of fate for your former
client to go from death row to a new
trial and in your eyes
uh how reasonable is it
it's not a matter of reasonable or
unreasonableness i mean is the question
to me is does
a defendant deserves deserve a fair
trial and i think he does any defendant
does that's our constitution that's what
our system is criminal justice system is
based on
and it is i mean bottom line it is
reasonable it's reasonable to expect
fairness in our system we've got one of
the best systems in the world
and scott never got that fair trial and
he
he deserves another shot at it why not
and
is it reasonable to think that a jury
can acquit him of course
this was a circumstantial evidence the
prosecution couldn't even couldn't even
prove
how this happened where it happened when
it happened
there was no forensic evidence
connecting him to it the whole the
entire thing was based on a lot of
hatred
people hated scott and a lot of it had
to do with the cheating and some of the
stuff he'd said
but that's not enough cases should not
be lost on things
girlfriend in front of the tv cameras it
certainly changes the mood in the
community and that's what happened here
lori your etsy and appreciate the time
here on law and crime daily
thank you for having me and still ahead
right here on the broadcast a florida
sheriff's deputy under arrest in an
alleged child abuse case involving
exorcism but first a botched rescue
attempt after a team calls 9-1-1
fearing he's dying after being stuck
under an overturned car seat
why the police say they're not legally
[Music]
responsible
a city government is trying to avoid
legal responsibility for the death of a
teen who called 9-1-1
twice and who eventually died when he
was pinned underneath
a car seat kyle plush used siri on his
iphone to call police begging for help
kyle was in his family's van in the
parking lot of his school before tennis
practice
body camera video showed two cincinnati
police officers
driving around the school but never
getting out of their cruisers city
investigators uncovered a series of
errors at the 9-1-1 call center
including computer problems which
prevented one operator
from hearing kyle here are pieces of his
outside the seven year old midfielder
the seven hills what parking lot yeah
if you want i am trapped in my bag
i probably don't have much time left to
tell my mom
that i love her if i die this is not a
joke
i'm trapped inside my gold i honda
odyssey van
in the southwest parking lot of seven
hill hills
send officers immediately i'm almost
dead
seven hours now down a little
attorneys representing the city of
cincinnati say kyle's death was a
tragedy but they're arguing that the
city is immune
from legal liability
i'd first like to take a moment to
recognize the tremendous loss
that the plush family has suffered
we remain so sorry for that loss
but the question before this court today
is whether the city and its employees
its 911 call takers
its police officers and former city
manager
are immune from liability and because
the facts in the complaint show that
none of the employees were reckless
and no other exception to immunity
applies
the trial court aired in denying the
city's motion to dismiss
at a minimum the plaintiffs have to
demonstrate that the conduct was
reckless and the recklessness is
a conscious disregard of a known or
obvious risk of harm and the the
employee has to know
that the conduct will in all probability
result in injury an attorney for the
plush family says the city should be
held liable for the failures which led
to kyle's death
the detailed 36 page 191 paragraph
complaint
with two preliminary expert reports
demonstrates
that no defendant is entitled to
immunity
in this case the case should proceed to
discovery and trial
those officers had enough this was a
high priority call
they were actually given an address and
if they had just typed the address into
their mobile data computer
or into their phone they'd have gone to
the north end of the
of the thrift store lot they never went
to the north end of the
thrift store a lot that address comes up
right next to where kyle was actually
located
they chose not to do it they were eating
they were
playing the radio they literally thought
this was a prank
and said that when they were interviewed
about this
this incident they didn't treat it as a
high priority call
they they didn't search the whole thrift
lot they never left their car
those are the arguments and when we come
back our experts break down the failures
and the legal hurdles which stand
in the way of kyle plush's family that's
right after this
on lawn crime daily
[Music]
we are back with more now about a
lawsuit surrounding the death of kyle
plush who called 9-1-1
twice seeking help after being trapped
in a van when a seat flipped over
plush said he was struggling to breathe
and fear dying
and he eventually did former 911
dispatcher police officer and swat team
member lisa lockwood is now
a law enforcement analyst she tells law
and crime that the operator who took the
teen's
second call is mostly to blame but that
the responding officers should also
shoulder
some of the faults when we got 911 call
pranks when i was a 9-1-1 dispatcher we
needed to follow up we needed to talk to
a parent children would always call
9-1-1
we needed to make contact at the home to
make sure it was not a prank
when you have somebody who's calling it
for an exigent
situation like that he couldn't breathe
he was trapped inside his vehicle
this is something that you would also
dispatch an ambulance to
having the foresight of if police
officers weren't able to
gain access to the vehicle for whatever
reason and having extra equipment with
an ambulance or a fire truck etc
to make sure and none of that was done
it seems as if
it was not taken seriously and i i
put the onus on the dispatcher who had a
second phone call and did not
disseminate that information to the
police officers
your job is to take a 9-1-1 call
dispatch the officers
and give every all information given on
that 9-1-1 call to the responding police
officers as a police officer your job is
to investigate the scene
find out what's going on why you are
there not to make
an assumption that it's a prank i think
11 minutes was a little bit
quick in making a decision to leave the
scene and not be able to
actually find the vehicle a little bit
more a foot patrol or maybe another
police officer
to back up and help so the legal issue
here brian is sovereign immunity it's
that basic concept that the government
isn't liable for wrongs unless the
government agrees that it can be sued or
waives
this sovereign immunity in certain areas
so that's the legal concept here
you found some cases that there have
been other issues in cincinnati how do
they bear on this
case yeah well aaron there's also an org
to that overcoming qualified immunity or
sovereign immunity
and that's if you can show that the
official violated a clearly established
either statutory
or constitutional right and that they
knew or should have known
uh that they were not allowed to do that
now you go backwards 2016
and cincinnati unfortunately had a very
similar situation with michael foster a
30 year old who's going through a mental
health um
situation where his landlord actually
called the police and they never showed
up
and so if you can get a little creative
as an attorney here you can show hey
there's a bit of a history with
cincinnati
of not responding to these 911 calls
and that because the the brass is
basically not cracking down on them for
doing this
it shows a system in which they have
allowed to do so which
led to the death of the plush family
it's an argument that takes some time to
articulate but it could be an argument
that wins in this case and to think that
some of the people responding thought
this might have been a prank i think
lisa handled
that explanation very very well exactly
it's
they didn't even try i mean it's a
failure not only from a procedural
standpoint i can bring all the
legal explanations and whatnot but as a
human being you hear a child's voice
and yes could it be the boy that cried
wolf but you've got to respond because
if it's not the boy that called wolf
we're talking about it here on long
crime daily and it becomes a devastating
story
exactly brian buckmeyer appreciate the
analysis when we come back a secret
court record
is now public for the former girlfriend
of pedophile jeffrey epstein
could it help prosecutors prove a
criminal case against jesus maxwell
[Music]
the words of millionaire pedophile
jeffrey epstein's former girlfriend are
now
public record a judge has unsealed
hundreds of pages of jesulin maxwell's
2016 deposition the british socialite
denied knowing or
participating in abuse of underage girls
with epstein
maxwell said she was a loyal friend to
epstein but that she was quote
not responsible for what jeffrey epstein
does maxwell is being held in federal
custody for allegedly helping to recruit
groom and sexually assault minors
a now former florida sheriff's deputy is
accused of trying to perform an
exorcism on a child christopher dautry
was
arrested after deputies say they
responded to a call of child abuse
according to court documents responding
officers found a child with a rifle
wearing a helmet and a bulletproof
vest the deputies say doherty told the
child to shoot
anyone who entered the apartment because
he was allegedly trying to perform an
exorcism on another child
doherty was booked into jail after a
mental health evaluation and is facing
child abuse
charges a massive settlement for a
company at the center of america's
opioid crisis
the maker of oxycontin has agreed to
plead guilty to three federal criminal
anti-kickback charges
purdue pharma will pay more than 8
billion dollars
and close down as a company it will be
dissolved and its assets will be used to
create a new public benefit company
that will make overdose rescue drugs it
will continue to make oxycontin to be
used as a painkiller
officials at the department of justice
say the company's responsibility doesn't
end there the company's in bankruptcy
so the corporate resolution is subject
to the bankruptcy court's approval
if it's approved this will be a
corporate settlement
in total of more than 8.3 billion
dollars additionally
members of the sackler family have
agreed to pay
225 million dollars in a civil
settlement that will provide civil
releases
only it's also important to note
that this resolution does not prohibit
future criminal or civil penalties
against purdue farmers executives or
employees
a miami attorney is accused of being
behind
a string of bank robberies in south
florida the fbi says
aaron honaker is a suspect in at least
five robberies or attempted bank
robberies
investigators say honaker was arrested
by police as he was attempting to enter
a bank of course records show he was
admitted to the florida bar in 2008 and
worked
for at least two law firms agents say he
targeted the banks over a two-week spree
and was and they caught him before he
could strike
again a woman charged in the death of a
florida law school professor will have
to remain behind bars as she awaits a
second trial
prosecutors say catherine mcbonnewell
was the messenger in a murder-for-hire
plot against victim dan markell
a jury was hung during magbono's first
trial for first-degree murder
her co-defendant cefrado garcia was
convicted and sentenced to life in
prison
mcbanoa's defense asked a judge to
release her from custody saying there
just isn't enough evidence against her
her attorney said at trial that she was
wrongly dragged into the conspiracy
through
an fbi wiretap by her then boyfriend
charlie adelson
who just happened to be the victim's
brother-in-law
the bump gave him the idea
to use catherine as a buffer
find out who it is call that number
knowing
that she she could say something wrong
she could do something wrong
to incriminate him the reason why he was
so confident with having her calls
because he knew she didn't know anything
but when catherine wants to know what is
this about the answer is
the less you know the better there's no
information flowing in between there
there's only one reason why a single
mother
of two young children
would sit in custody for three years in
confinement
risking it all
innocent so
brian here here's the thing when you get
a hung jury on a huge count like this
that's a bit of a win it's not a
complete win but it's a bit of a win how
do you represent your client going
forward after that
point yeah so i think the defense here
made slightly a slight error in terms of
their argument
it's not that there's not enough
evidence to hold their defendant in
because there is
uh the burden of proof or proof or
unreasonable doubt for a trial is much
higher than that necessary to hold
someone in
i think the argument here is that the
evidence against her has gotten weaker
because they're able to poke holes on it
after a trial and weaker evidence should
mean a reduction in bail or
in the alternative release and
ultimately a
a chance that you could be out from
behind bars pending the next case if
prosecutors move forward
brian appreciate the insight a bit of a
bumpy ride behind the scenes we
lost a real connection to terry but
she'll be back next time with us here on
law and crime daily
[Music]
you